salud en directo América de France 24 me
acompaña en el estudio mar Romero sala
mar bienvenida buena mañana de lunes nos
vamos a China donde vuelve a estar en
debate su política de cero covid Así es
Raúl buenos días un tema que hemos
debatido aquí ya varias veces y que
ahora está volviendo a tomar fuerza
parece que también estas protestas están
despertando esas posibilidades de
reabrir después de medidas muy estrictas
muy estrictas que han caracterizado a
China a lo largo de toda la pandemia
Igualmente por parte de los oficiales
del gobierno chino siguen defendiendo
haber tenido este tipo de medidas hasta
ahora escuchemos
quiero destacar que desde que llegó la
pandemia china ha continuado optimizando
y mejorando sus políticas de prevención
y control según la evolución de la
pandemia y ha protegido la vida y la
salud de las personas al máximo
los hechos prueban que las políticas de
prevención y control de China han sido
científicas y efectivas
en términos de cifras vemos que al menos
china reconoce 5.200 muertes Aunque
sabemos que eso es al menos algo
debatible por los métodos de conteo que
han tenido y tienen una de las tasas de
muertes diarias también por población de
las más bajas del mundo en este momento
mucho menor por ejemplo que en Chile
Brasil o Canadá por poner ejemplos de
nuestro de nuestro continente el número
de contagios diarios están alrededor
entre los 30.000 40.000 pero recordemos
de nuevo que la población china es
inmensa y que sin ir más lejos Francia
está teniendo muchos más casos por día o
Japón por ejemplo cuando lo comparas en
su población Así que en ese sentido al
menos en términos de cifras Es cierto
que estas medidas han logrado mantener
muy bajas las cifras de muertes y de
contagios mar Pero digamos qué situación
puede enfrentar China si abandona su
política de cero covid pues es muy
difícil de predecir porque hay muchas
formas de reabrir podría ser más o menos
gradual podría ser con a más tasas o
menos tasas de vacunación pero han
habido varios estudios que intentan
hacer esta predicción y en general el
consenso está en que una reapertura
podría llegar a causar entre 1,3 por lo
bajo o dos coma uno más de dos millones
de muertes en el país dadas las
condiciones de ahora si se reabre pues
las si se abandonan las cuarentenas
sobre todo y estas medidas tan estrictas
es importante decir que estos son
predicciones que por ejemplo tienen en
cuenta como si se reabriera mañana
digamos no Y eso no tiene por qué ser
así no quiere decir que ya vayamos a ver
pues esta cantidad de fallecidos pero de
nuevo importante recordar que eso la
población de China es de 1400 miles de
millones y muchas veces se ha planteado
esa política de covid cero como si fuera
una decisión que ellos tomaron de forma
relativamente caprichosa pero con las
condiciones demográficas de China vemos
también lo que podría haber sucedido
cada país es totalmente diferente mar y
Cuál es la situación de vacunación en el
país No En ese sentido Claro ese es el
gran dilema que hay ahora mismo
alrededor de reabrir o no Cómo está la
tasa de vacunación en el país en los
últimos reportes de las autoridades por
ejemplo dicen que el 90% de la población
mayor de 60 años ya ha recibido una
dosis pero en estos momentos de la
pandemia una primera dosis sabemos que
ya no sirve de mucho Entonces vamos a
ver unas cifras que además muestran por
ejemplo la cantidad de población
vacunada al día está cayendo a mínimos
es decir cada vez hay menos personas que
reciben una dosis de vacunas al día
Entonces a qué se debe esto Pues bueno
hay mucha desinformación hay mucha
desconfianza también y además hay mucha
parte de la población que se ha digamos
apoyado en esas ideas de covid Cero y en
esas estrictas medidas y eso han hecho
que vean pues la vacunación como mucho
menos necesaria y a que sabían que
también iban a estar aislados o que se
iban a cerrar rápidamente a la que
hubiera casos no sabemos si eso va a
cambiar a partir de ahora además también
pues han habido algunas críticas
alrededor de las vacunas que se han
hecho en China porque parece que al
menos su efecto es un poco menos
duradero no dura tanto pero por ejemplo
en una entrevista con una cadena de
televisión china ayer la Organización
Mundial de la Salud le daba un
espaldarazo a este tipo de fármacos
evaluamos varias vacunas hechas en China
y todas cumplieron con nuestros
estándares han sido aprobadas para uso
de emergencia y se han usado de forma
efectiva en todo el mundo
Eso sí muchos países ven que una
estrategia de micks and match es buena
por ejemplo tener dos dosis o una de una
vacuna y tener el refuerzo de un tipo
distinto de vacuna
Y entonces mar ahora que sigue bueno es
la gran pregunta que tenemos todos y
solo lo saben los oficiales del gobierno
chino Aunque tenemos algunas pistas de
los últimos comunicados que han
publicado no por ejemplo han hablado de
redoblar las campañas de vacunación
especialmente en las personas mayores de
esta parte tan crítica de la población
china que parece que no ha estado
respondiendo tanto estas vacunas
entonces Perdona estas vacunas pues a
estas campañas o estos incentivos de
recibir la vacuna Entonces por ejemplo
una de las propuestas del gobierno es
hacer campañas puerta a puerta en los
hogares de las residencias de adultos
mayores también importante recordar hay
vacunas que se están investigando de ARN
mensajero que parece que tienen una
protección algo más prolongada y
entonces pues bueno al final la pregunta
que queda también es si todo esto podría
haberse hecho antes no hay muchos países
que tuvieron medidas muy estrictas para
prepararse para una reapertura parece
que ahora está todo siendo rápido y
corriendo Pero bueno vamos a ver qué
decisiones se toman Bueno vamos a ver
qué decisiones se toman y también
digamos con una vuelta del tapabocas en
algunos países sobre todo en lugares
cerrados de cara al invierno
evidentemente donde se incrementan estas
enfermedades respiratorias y como lo
recordamos el covid 19 todavía no ha
desaparecido desgraciadamente todavía no
mar Muchísimas gracias como siempre por
toda esta información mañana con más
salud mañana